Guten morgen tim mit wie vielen gamern.
Aux
Buch netz politik nummer dreihundertsechzehn frisch auf gebrüllt am vierzehnten oktober zweitausendneunzehn von uns.
Ist das dreihundertsechzehn ich dachte mir ich dachte hundertsechzehn hast du recht meine güte.
Ja meine gute.
Wenn man nicht meinen ne.
Der open world mehr open world geht hier nicht.
Das netzwerk.
Alles dreidimensional alles live alles gestreamt alles irre.
Voller alles voller gegner mit künstlicher intelligenz fast fast realistisch intelligente.
Da muss man auch alle alle sinne wirklich geschafft haben und vollkommen hellwach sein wenn man hier überhaupt mitspielen will.
Ja
Also sowohl am mikrofon als auch am kopfhörer.
Letzte sendung haben wir viel feedback bekommen.
Das ist wahr wir haben wieder mehr batman betrieben haben.
Leute beschmutzt.
Da haben sich leute angesprochen gefühlt,
kann man auf jeden fall in den in den kommentaren dann in gänze sehen wer das möchte ich habe aber auch.
Mich mit extension rebellion unterhalten also mit nicht es gibt ja nicht
von berlin und es war sehr schön das gespräch ging nämlich so hallo ja hallo wer bist du ja die a linus ich habe kritik für dich.
Okay was haben wir denn was haben wir denn also noch nicht hat sie noch nicht vorgestellt oder so ne sag ja was haben wir denn für kritik.
Was war das für eine gelegenheit und dass man so zu irgendwas.
Im text und,
ja also die kritik wäre in dem in dem blogpost zu dem buch kapitel was ich für das extrem im buch beigesteuert habe da ist unten drunter in google maps link.
Ich habe ich gesagt habe ich gesagt.
Also ich habe mich dann kurz mit der fassung gerungen und dann habe ich,
erklärt dass dieser text von ihnen kann ich nicht geschrieben das war quasi die bitte von.
Einschließlich des links.
Kaputt.
Ja da sieht man die volksfront für datenschutz ist auch da wird da eine rolle,
ja da musste ich mich sofort rechtfertigen was mir eingefallen ist ja da sind buch kapitel hinten zu schreiben wo ihr wie google maps links von ihnen unkritisch übernommen werden.
Ja also schön hätte gerne noch weiter diskutiert haben wir dann auch keine sorge,
ansonsten wurde in den kommentaren ja,
einerseits sehr es gab sehr viel positive zuspruch über unsere kritik an den progressiven bewegungen sich in dem krieg schau plätzen zu ergehen.
Nicht nee und es gab auch sehr vehement,
sehr elemente kritik wir hätten irgendwie jutta foods kritik mehr raum geben müssen und mehr wiedergeben müssen wo ich,
ich denke genau das nicht zu tun weil der kern der sendung aber,
okay und zwar insbesondere wurde dann angemerkt wir hätten benennen müssen das mahatma gandhi.
Ein sagen wir mal absolut inakzeptabel frauenbild hatte,
also frauen sehr schlecht behandelt vergewaltigung und sonstiges spielen da eine rolle.
Das argument hab ich ich hab mir sehr viel mühe gegeben dem argument zu folgen also man hat man nur zeit
achtundvierzig glaube ich tot
und mir ist jetzt auch nicht aufgefallen dass extension rebellion gesagt hätte wir müssen jetzt im rahmen des zivilen ungehorsam mit dem sie sich auf einmal hat man dann die beziehen jetzt irgendwie massenvergewaltigungen durchführen oder sowas aber was mir dann auch klar wurde tim,
wir müssen also das ist das problem ist noch tiefer gehen weil also,
albert einstein hat seine cousine geheiratet das heißt wir müssen jetzt die relativitätstheorie analysieren und immanuel kant
ja das war ein glühende rassist und der hat die hat uns die aufklärung gebracht das heißt die müssen wir jetzt auch noch ablehnen.
Das wird also diese diese diese rassen ideologie der aufklärung ja wie wir da jetzt seit jahrhunderten einen einem rassisten holt liegen ne das geht geht so überhaupt nicht da können wir so nicht weitermachen.
Was linus damit eigentlich sagen will in seiner ebenso eignen art und weise.
Man kann glaube ich sehr wohl zwischen,
sinnvollen beiträgen und weniger hilfreichen beiträgen einzelner personen unterscheiden ohne jetzt gleich da alles in einen topf werfen zu müssen und aus dem einen das andere automatisch zu diskreditiert.
Wer das übrigens sehr gut erkannt hat ist luisa neubauer ich glaube die kann man sagen die deutsche greta.
Naja.
Deutschland glaube ich einen ähnlichen sagen wir mal.
Das würde jetzt impliziert dass sie dass sie sozusagen den selben weg also diese selbe methode und dieselbe initiative,
hat aber sie ist auf jeden fall diejenige die freie future bewegung in deutschland medial repräsentiert,
vielleicht auch anfährt keine ahnung das kann man so oder so sehen auf jeden fall ist hier eine der sichtbaren gesichter und das scheint auch nicht die schlechteste wahl gewesen zu sein weil es auch ganz gut im sprechen von ganzen sätzen.
Ich wollte euch gerade nicht sagen dass sie quasi worte die deutsche greta wollte ich loben ihre weisheit und symbolkraft wollte sie da jetzt nicht irgendwie das sollte positiv sein.
Ich habe das jetzt auch nicht negativ ausgeht ich wollte nur sagen wir sehen sie nicht identisch in einer identischen rolle.
Und was sagt luisa neubauer hier im interview mit dem zdf.
Aux
Ja jetzt erkannt.
Warum eigentlich so radikal dass jetzt sogar die eltern mit ihrem suv im stau stehen bleiben wenn sie ihre kinder zur kita bringe.
Ja
Warum so radikal.
Ja das ist richtig krasse das geht.
Geht ja an die wurzel der existenz.
Auf sehr schön aus wie wenig schenkung,
da eigentlich in diesem diskurs immer noch vertreten ist,
ja fahrt doch vielleicht fahrrad oder zweirad geht auch motorisierte geht auch ganz gut durch den stau kam auch woanders langfahren kann man auch früher aufstehen kann man alles machen kann man alles irgendwie mal darüber nachdenken was man eigentlich so tut in seinem leben genau darum geht's nämlich gerade.
Ich finde das äh immer sehr schön,
wenn es solche blockade situation in berlin eigentlich die ganze woche extension belgien hat ja hier wirklich an,
so vielen,
stellen in berlin so viele aktionen gemacht alle möglichen brücken dicht gemacht am umweltministerium übernachtet und es war wirklich die haben sich da total.
Zentrale haben sich an gekettet.
Sie haben sich da ausgepowert mit mit den mit vielfältigen aktionen.
Selten selten ist es irgendwie mit der polizei ruppig geworden also das dafür wurden sie ja auch viel kritisiert ne das jetzt irgendwie mit der polizei auch in absprachen getreten sind und dann war aber das ist,
tatsächlich gut gelaufen ist irgendwie die räumungen waren dann friedlich irgendwie so quasi
friedliche situationen gehabt oder ja dann räumen wir jetzt in der demonstrieren ja okay dann erweckt tragen lassen polizei die paar hundert leute da weggeschnappt gibt 's auch schöne bilder.
Wie alle dann freu dich spaß für die ganze familie so da alle haben irgendwie ein lächeln im gesicht vertragen sich polizei räumt,
leute lassen sich räumen klar dann kam also die haben das irgendwie glaube ich ganz gut gemacht da kann man
sagen das ist das ist denen sehr gut gelungen diese woche das konnte natürlich nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und hat dann der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung wie wir wissen die speerspitze,
der des progress der progressiven elemente unserer gesellschaft ja ein interview gegeben indem der die frankfurter allgemeine zeitung als rechtskonservativ es bleibt hat selbstverständlich jutta dietfurt alle
zeit und alle platz der welt gegeben um zu erklären warum extension rebellen jetzt irgendwie schlecht ist ja,
unter dem rationales mus einer endzeit weg.
Hat sie dann da nochmal in ruhe erklären,
können ja müsste ich esoterische drama konnte nochmal so richtig drauf hat und da sieht man eben,
von mir aus jutta dietfurt ja sogar gut in der regel ist ja gut eben,
das gegenteil von gut gemeint aber sie hat seit jetzt die meint es wahrscheinlich gut aber
auch hier diese wirkung der dann diese diese diskussion über extension rebellen als irgendwie nicht ziemliche komische sekte das schadet der umwelt bewegung glaube ich enorm und insbesondere wenn sich dann
wenn jutta dietfurt eben nicht die vergiftetes das vergiftete angebot erkennt was ihr davon der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung gemacht wird.
In der sie ja sonst nicht zu wort kommt mit mit also nicht nicht in so einem ausmaß und nicht in dieser vehemenz,
als ich das getwittert habe wurde dann auch direkt angemerkt dass ja die genossen kurz und rieger auch beim klassenfahrt schreiben
und ich habe mir dann aber nicht die mühe gegeben noch zu erklären dass es eben ein unterschied ist,
du progressive positionen in einem rechtskonservative bürgerlichen blatt unterbringt und da irgendwie,
ne datenschutz und kritik an der regierung und,
themen zum cyber krieg und worüber die kolumnen regelmäßig gehen ja wenn du da.
In dieses milieu halt deine position trägst die deiner gesamt bewegung zuträglich sind aber ich habe irgendwie frank und constanze nie
zum beispiel in der faz gelesen dass sie sagen hier was weiß ich digital courage ist eine rationale endzeit sekte ja das das.
Oder die volksfreund für daten.
Die volksfront für datenschutz oder so ne die haben wir die schießen halt nicht in die eigenen reihen das ist das was ich versucht habe zu erklären aber ich hab auch gemerkt dass es,
dass ich da offenbar nicht ganz so gut drin bin das zu erklären zumindest haben das einige leute nicht verstanden habe ich es nicht geschafft in das zu erklären da bin ich dann an mir selber bescheid hat.
Man kann ja äh das auch.
Intellektuell aufgreifen weiterdenken hab ich auch alles gar nichts gegen aber wie das gerade bei der luisa neubau im gespräch sehr gut rauskam einfach diese einfache fashion mit.
Ja hallo können wir uns vielleicht mal über das unterhalten was ja eigentlich von allem mehr oder weniger unisono gefordert ist und was hier,
eigentlich das problem ist das sind halt einfach alles solche quer schuss debatten
vor allem dann leute mal sehr zu pass kommen die dann was weiß ich mit der ein oder anderen person oder bewegung noch irgendein hühnchen zu rupfen haben aus irgendwelchen anderen persönlichen beleidigt seiten heraus
der meinung sind sie könnten ihn jetzt nicht komplett zustimmen oder wie wir das letzte mal schon erwähnt haben so dieses meine
meine deutungshoheit ist in gefahr ja das sind ja auch alles phänomene die man einfach immer wieder sieht und da muss man vielleicht auch einfach mal so ein bisschen,
zurückstellen dann seine eigene rolle und sagen.
Okay und wir wollten immer wir wollten immer dass die jugend jetzt langsam mal hier.
In wallung kommt ich meine wie viel jahre haben wir uns über,
die sogenannte unpolitische generation beschwert ja also ich hab,
weiß ich nicht in welchem maße ich das getan habe aber diese debatte selber war ja im im im raum,
und da steht ja in gewisser hinsicht auch dass man ja selber sehr viel politischer gewesen wäre das würde ich jetzt gar nicht behaupten wollen also ich persönlich jetzt nicht unbedingt aber die zeit natürlich schon,
und wie das immer so ist in der gesellschaft kommt halt immer alles in fällen,
und jetzt ist mal wieder so eine welle und da müssen wir auch voll mitnehmen und ihr auch den raum geben und auch irgendwie eine gewisse,
zugestehen selbst wenn es mal ein bisschen,
verdreht und übers ziel hinaus und was weiß ich ist und so weil ohne das.
Kein fortschritt so und man hat jetzt die erste welle gesehen in punkto datenschutz man sieht jetzt die zweite welle in puncto,
umwelt und da ist auch einfach höchste zeit es ist einfach höchste zeit ist einfach so und.
Bezahlt die leute die einfach seit jahrzehnten bremsen mal komplett hier aus dem gleis zu fahren fertig.
So machen wir das mit den methoden die wir wählen.
Genau und selbst wenn man sich bei galli und kannst oder einschalten ab guckt alles okay ne.
Nein willst du nicht machen.
Ich bin jetzt überzeugt also ich werde das ich werde jetzt hier die.
Die gravitation nicht mehr als begründung heranziehen.
Ja das war's dann auch schon mit den lustigen themen heute.
Ja leider.
Wir hatten ich glaube wir müssen die geschehnisse,
in halle jetzt nicht mehr.
Besonders zusammenfassen das ist um die welt gegangen das hat alle beschäftigt ein.
Naja grob schon vielleicht.
Ein irrer nazi terrorist,
hat versucht eine synagoge anzugreifen ist an der tür gescheitert und hat daraufhin eine vorbei laufende frau,
erschossen und einen jungen mann der in einer einem döner restaurant in der dönerbude irgendwie war erschossen bis dann irgendwie weggefahren wurde,
gefasst und verhaftet so.
Kann man das ganz gut zusammenfassen.
Hat das.
An einem ich glaub dem höchsten irischen feiertag dir also stand jetzt mal ich dachte das wäre ein anderer aber ich kenn mich mit feiertagen nicht aus und ja.
Ein.
Schreck ein schreckliches vorkommnisse das natürlich jetzt dann auch allerlei diskussionen herbeigeführt wenn eine solche einschneidenden situation passiert und,
da gibt's mehrere facetten die besprochen gehören das eine ist dass der sich relativ klar,
einer im weitesten sinne dieser treue und medienkultur bedient der sich ja auch schon der irre aus,
bedient hat,
also das wir hatten es damals auch schon besprochen dass irgendwie diese foren angeht wie und sowas.
Und das ist natürlich dann auch gleich unseren politikern aufgefallen dass das dass das so ist das kann ja nur wieder was mit dem internet zu tun haben kannst nur eine quelle geben.
Fragen wir doch mal unseren.
Aux
Viele der täter erstaunlich es gibt ja zum glück nicht viele täter.
Was was meine erste reaktion war ich dachte mir so was er ist immer noch in minister.
Jetzt wird's schon wieder weitgehend verdreckt also herr seehofer ist sich also,
schade auch wenn ich noch die ältesten kamellen nochmal irgendjemand hat ja schon die piraten partei gegen,
gekämpft und die hat schon fast nichts mehr zu sagen also.
Wann wann war dieses diese kinderspiel debatte das muss auch so irgendwie.
Winnenden mit winnenden ging das irgendwie so richtig los in deutschland.
Stimmt.
Der anschlag in winnenden der amokläufer der halt der schüler der in seiner schüler rumgelaufen ist und diverse mitschüler.
Zweitausend.
Lehrer erschossen hat.
Ja vor zehn jahren.
Das über zehn jahre her genommen.
Der hatte der kann auch aus der gamescom.
Na ja der hat äh halt äh die haben halt sein zimmer durchsucht und anstatt da halt ein computer und er war halt am geben,
wieso ziemlich alle kinder in deutschland so ja das ist halt einfach mal das was man macht geben heißt übrigens spiel kurze erklärung ja.
Ja
man spielt halt so und manche spielen diese manche spielen das und jeder spielt was anderes und viele spielen halt auch ja ist so ballerst spieler der ein oder anderen natur,
und auch wenn ich selber jetzt nicht besonderer fan davon bin halt auch sehr viel first passenden schulter strategische spieler was es auch immer ist früher war es.
Counter strike das große ding heute sind wir bei fortnite angekommen dieses diese spiele typus nicht weggehen aber was er ja hier quasi inszeniert ist ja.
Da sitzen diese leute zusammen ja und wie in so einer verdeckten operation tun sie ja nur als würden sie ja spiele.
Spielen ja aber eigentlich benutzen sie dieses software zur planung von anschließen.
Was für ein unsinn also es ist.
Ja was für ein unsinn und das ist insofern auch ganz lustig als das ja die bundeswehr nun selber.
Und dafür kommt vielleicht diese diese denke auch her.
Die bundeswehr sehr wohl oder sagen wir mal das militär generell in den usa ist das ja schon ein bisschen länger so sozusagen
diese spiele natürlich auch als soldaten training benutzt weil es eben nachweislich deine sinne schärfen deine reaktionszeit et cetera dann aufmerksamkeit für details schärft ist halt so
und tatsächlich wirbt sogar die bundeswehr auf plakaten irgendwie für ihre kriegseinsätze mit mehr open world geht nicht.
Ja multiplayer pipapo t und die gehen ja auch zur gamescom zu der computerspiele messe in köln mit einem riesigen stand ja und.
Und beschweren sich über der republika nicht auch noch darum.
Ja und das publikum kann nicht hin dürfen die ich will das mal.
Versuchen zu erklären wenn also was menschen tun ist
also unabhängig davon ob es jetzt verwirrte mörder sind oder was auch immer menschen haben kulturen und an diese kulturen wird appelliert ja,
das tut die bundeswehr mit ihrer werbung die sich auf computer spieler bezieht.
Das tun keine ahnung
friday it's for future und extension rebellion indem sie logos schaffen und versuchen
eben eine eine kultur zu kreieren und diese computerspiele kultur ist enorm groß ich weiß nicht genau aber ich glaube die irgendwie in deutschland wird jetzt irgendwie die geschätzt dass irgendwie so um die dreißig millionen,
oder vierzig millionen aktive computer spielerinnen gibt ja.
Ich die zahl habe ich jetzt irgendwo gelesen ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen wie
stark die fundiert die ist aber sagen wir mal so 'ne playstation findet man schon in vielen haushalten oder so ein nintendo oder was man ne und.
Na klar also es ist einfach.
Computerspiele kultur ist enorm verbreitet ähnlich wie vielleicht film.
Sogar sogar in meinem haushalt findet man das ja.
Wird das geduldet ne so und an solche kulturen rennen wird natürlich auch appelliert ja das,
wird der wird geworben da gibt's dann diese diese youtube,
schwach martin den beauty pay und sowas ne.
Die sich damit sich damit auseinandersetzen das ist etwas was
was cool ist wie eine band oder so eine band musik stile prägen ja auch die menschen ja das dann irgendwie hören rap-musik oder mail oder hast du alles nicht gesehen ne und natürlich hat dieser,
nazi terrorist versucht eben auch,
an kulturen zu appellieren und natürlich appelliert er an irgendwie diese computerspiel kultur wo es eben,
spiele gibt bei denen töten eine zentrale rolle spielt,
der appelliert an diese troll kultur bedient sich also der der typischen die ingo hatte diesen
versucht diesen leicht,
ja also diesen zynischen humor irgendwie auch mitzumachen der in diesem foren geprägt ist um da eben 'ne anschluss fähigkeit und eine nähe zu finden der,
deswegen tut er das das heißt aber natürlich nicht dass aus allen computer spielern irgendwie serien mörder werden oder massenmörder das ist eben eine
ein umgekehrter schluss.
Gleichzeitig werden natürlich jetzt die die computerspiele
interessengruppen die wehren sich natürlich jetzt auch mit vehemenz dagegen wird natürlich gesagt ja interessiert euch das etwa nicht er da mit den mit den massenmörder spielt oder so ne.
Das ist das führt halt nirgendwohin also das ist es wird,
das was er seehofer sich da vorstellt wie so vieles was er sich vorstellt entspricht eben nicht unbedingt eine relativ realität das
dieser mensch jetzt zum massenmörder geworden ist oder zum mörder geworden ist ein massenmörder werden wollte.
Weil der computer gespielt hat sondern weil das ein blühender antisemiten ist der irgendwie mit den falschen leuten abgehangen hat und die falschen ideen von denen bekommen hat.
Ja der kommt nicht aus der gamer szene der kommt aus der nazi szene und,
stehe einfach nicht warum unsere politik nicht in der lage ist selbst bei so einer faktenlage das einfach mal klar zu benennen paar tage vorher hat doch wieder ministerin,
exit.
Haben sie weder die kohle gekürzt.
Kohle gestrichen ja wo irgendwie potenzielle aussteiger aus der nazi szene unterstützung behalten also
warum wundern sie sich überhaupt noch dass das passiert wenn wenn wenn sie so eine strategie verfolgen und das ist ja schon seit jahren so das prinzip alles was in irgendeiner form helfen kann
wird die kohle weggenommen wird nicht gefördert wird auch irgendwie moralisch nicht unterstützt
aber dann beschweren sich das jetzt irgendwie so jetzt haben wir die nazis schon wieder irgendwas böses,
gemacht aber es war wahrscheinlich so wegen der computerspiele sonst sind die eigentlich ganz nett.
Also anders kann ich das schon gar nicht mehr interpretieren also das ist jetzt nicht nur ein versäumnis hier im prinzip machen die sich eigentlich der förderung schuldig.
Er hat ein manifest verfasst hochgeladen indem er seine ganzen selbstgebastelten waffen irgendwie beschreibt und erklärt.
Was ein ganz interessantes detail ist dass er halt zwar als hochgerissen det beschrieben wurde ne man hatte ja so,
gleich den ersten meldungen ja hatte ganz viel waffen dabei ganz viel.
Hatte er auf jeden fall ne.
Ja äh da hat er auch aber man macht sich ja da sozusagen,
also in meinem kopf entsteht dann sofort so ein so ein so ein so ein bild von,
professionellen waffensysteme die willst irgendwoher,
im container fertig betriebsbereit abgeladen wurden aber offensichtlich hatte er durchaus probleme an solche waffen heranzukommen oder kein kohle dafür das kann natürlich auch sein hat sich das alles selber gebaut.
Präsentiert dann irgendwie in diesem dokument stolz irgendwie da seine selbstgebastelten sachen wo ich dann auch gleich schon auf die nächste debatte warte drei d drucker sind terror werkzeug.
Kam der aus der kam aus der make-up.
Zähne genau das das das das fehlt jetzt auch noch so ja also die die fäden ja plastik zusammen irgendwie das ist ja ja klar waren da bestimmte griffe und patronen,
halter waren dann irgendwie mit so vielen moment zusammen.
Hat ja dann auch ein schlechtes entsprechend schlecht funktioniert offenbar abgesehen davon dass eine gesamte strategie keine war,
schreibt er sogar selber dass er kein plan hat oder ich gehe mal gucken was geht aber.
Florian fixiert sich halt selbst mit seinen tollen zielen und was er da alle für highscore erzielen könnte ja deshalb von so schief mainz,
die rede und so natürlich spricht der so ein bisschen die sprache die man in dieser kultur oder in dieser zeit erreichbar nur das jetzt in der gamer wir benutzen ja diese begriffe auch ohne uns jetzt irgendwie als,
in der gamer szene zu verordnen und dementsprechend ist das jetzt auch
nichts anderes als seehofer the time move an ja dann deine jugend und und und sprach prägung liegt jetzt halt einfach fünfzig jahre zurück,
sitz halt eine andere sprache kennst du nicht aber,
ist ganz normal kann man bestätigen so redet man heute.
Ja dieses.
Also genau mit diesem manifest möchte er ja also er will ja anschluss fähigkeit finden er will irgendwie.
Will sich anbinden an das wie menschen sprechen will quasi zeigen ey ich bin einer von euch es ist kein so weiter weg sagt er auch sein erklärtes ziel ist erstens,
diese waffen zu testen zweitens möglichst viele menschen animieren es im gleich zu tun.
Und drittens so viele menschen wie möglich zu töten bevorzugt juden.
Antifa auch gegangen oder eine moschee oder so aber.
Sie mir am ende relativ egal er hat ja dann.
Nachdem er durch die tür nicht durchgekommen ist einfach irgendwelche menschen erschossen was eben auch zeigt dass der typ halt ernsthaft.
Ernsthaft an einer waffe hat ja und also dann zeigt alles auch wenn man das liest sehr schaurig was was bei dem irgendwie schief sitzt.
Jetzt hat der.
Ist es so wir werden natürlich jetzt eine reihe an diskussionen haben wir haben diese gamer diskussion hat.
Horst seehofer eröffnet wir werden außerdem eine diskussion über diese von der cdu herrn mittel berg sogenannte melde pflicht für hass postings diskutieren denn.
Es ist tatsächlich so dass sich insbesondere diese nazis gruppen über,
telegram gruppen koordinieren telegram ein,
messenger eine messenger app angeblich mit unternehmen sitz in berlin noch nie irgendjemand irgendjemand hat noch nie jemand irgendjemandem gesehen betrieben von einem,
russischen staatsbürger glaube ich.
Angeblich ist das entwicklerteam in dubai.
Ihr weiß der geier wo die es ist ja auch eigentlich egal wo die sind.
Also nach eigenen angaben sind sie,
angeblich in dubai aber auch das scheint irgendwie so ein bisschen unklar zu sein es gab ganz am anfang als sie populär wurden gab es diese berlin story die keiner so richtig verifizieren bekommen hat das war alles ein bisschen unklar,
vielfalt das ding ganz andere routen russland also sagen wir mal,
soweit ich das über blicke in russland eher populärer als im rest wird aber quasi eine ganzen westlichen welt von teilen benutzt und hat sich in der letzten zeit besonders bei rechten netzen ein wenig,
po polarisiert da frage ich mich natürlich warum nur.
Ja
Die haben also es gibt da verschiedene telekom gruppen in den man zum beispiel dieses manifest zirkulieren in denen auch das video zirkulieren zu dem wir gleich auch nochmal
kommen also wir werden jetzt eine diskussion nochmal wieder darüber führen,
das verschlüsselte messenger
zu greifbar sind frage ich mich.
Kann ich nur noch mal wiederholen vielleicht täuscht mich da auch meine wahrnehmung aber ich saß ja eigentlich selber mit drin in der sachverständigen anhörung mit der debatte wo die tatverdacht.
Straftat bestände aufgewertet wurden für quellen teka und diese.
Also ich würde jetzt vermuten dass also wenn man sich dazu hinreißen ließe auch weiße massenmörder als terroristen zu bezeichnen.
Statt als attentäter gamer,
und verwirrte einzeltäter dann müsste nach meiner lesart des gesetzes problemlos,
der zugriff auf diese gruppen des abhören dieser person möglich sein,
es ist auch tatsächlich nicht so als wäre es mit schwierigkeit verbunden in diese telegramm gruppen einfach rein zu kommen.
Also die kann ein bundesamt für verfassungsschutz oder eine polizei.
Sehr sehr einfach überwachen das ist jetzt nicht so dass die da besonders.
Hinterm hintern berg halten würden,
mit ihren zugängen und mit ihren ansichten insofern da sehe ich,
auch eine fehlgeleiteten aber auch eine in zukunft stattfinden der debatte und dann haben wir natürlich die diskussion über den livestream denn der typ hat sich an seinen bundeswehr helm in,
handy geknetet welches sein sein gesicht seine sicht quasi ins internet streamen bleibt.
Genau und zwar auf twitch.
Genau twitch hat nach.
Gamer szene ist.
Genau ja ist es ist tatsächlich gamma zähne wir tatsächlich von diesen play leuten benutzen oder also auch nee moment ich weiß nicht ob let's place der haupt inhalt von twitch sind aber viele let's place finden auf twitch statt.
Das kann man sogar so sagen dass das
wesentliches mit ihrer route aber ich glaub dass die eigentlich entscheidung für dieses netzwerk ist weniger da drin liegt dass es sowas mit der maschine zu tun hat als das da so sagen,
geringere hürden gibt ein livestream auch sofort freigeschaltet zu bekommen was
bei youtube halt nicht ganz so einfach.
Ja twitch hat auf jeden fall dann bekannt gegeben des video wurde live angeschaut von fünf personen.
Und im weiteren verlauf dann noch von zweitausendzweihundert quasi in der aufzeichnung angeschaut bis twitch ist gelöscht hat.
Mit anderen worten das gesamte thema livestreaming alles was wir jetzt über livestreaming von videos diskutieren betrifft fünf personen die das gesehen haben.
Die aufzeichnung die ihm dann.
In windeseile von twitch gelöscht wurde,
wie das so ist wenn inhalte aus dem internet verschwinden sollen die viele menschen dann aus welchem grund auch immer sehen möchten.
Die ploppen natürlich jetzt an anderen stellen hoch und finden sehr viel mehr zugriff e dort.
Es wird jetzt natürlich eine debatte darüber geben dass livestreaming nicht mehr erlaubt sein soll oder soll irgendwie verzögert oder verspätet oder nur nur mit personalausweis im internet oder was auch immer.
So irgendwie alles muss jetzt zeitverzögert und überprüft sein und so ja.
Ach ja das war auch schön ja,
irgendwie also das könnte halt das das wird jetzt hier auch nochmal auf uns zukommt wenn man auch hier wieder sagen müssen der livestream ist nicht das problem das problem,
ist nicht der livestream das ist ein nazi und nicht ein livestream das nazi und nicht ein gamer,
aber auch diese diskussion wird also auf uns zukommen.
Ich ja es ist einfach mich macht das ein bisschen fassungslos das einfach wo sind einfach die klaren aussagen zu dass wir ein nazi problem haben wo wo wo wo wo findet das statt.
Also selbst wenn es nebenbei noch bestätigt werden würde von der einen oder anderen finden person,
allein solche neben kriegs schauplätze die hier eröffnet werden,
machen die ganze debatte sofort wieder zunichte,
weil das ist nicht das problem das problem kennt man das problem ist einfach eine eine immer offener agierenden
nazi szene die das vor allem auch deshalb tut weil sie einfach keine entsprechenden repressionen aus dem staat offenbar mehr zu erwarten hat die teilweise von der polizei gedeckt wird die auch von diesem,
verfassungsschutz nicht in die schranken gewesen wird meine wie lange haben wir jetzt schon diese ganze debatte mit
ja hier in das urteil,
ja da müssen wir halt mehr mittel in den verfassungsschutz reinschieben so dann ist das jetzt auch,
passiert und was ist jetzt ja immer noch genau die gleiche scheiße und was,
das nächste diskussion ja da müssen wir mehr mitteln der verfassungsschutz reinschieben
das ist eine endlos schleife die dir überhaupt nicht mehr aufhört und vor allem bringt es halt auch nichts wenn der verfassungsschutz dann die ganzen nazis auch noch finanziert
damit sie dann irgendwie irgendwelche informationen liefern können wir brauchen da auch gar keine informationen mehr.
Da muss man einfach nur noch gegen vorgehen weil das einfach so offen alles stattfindet,
ich glaube nicht dass es irgendein informationsmaterial gibt es gibt einfach einen entscheidungssatz mangel und und der wird halt offensichtlich und dazu halt auch noch.
Eine politik die einfach jedem zivilgesellschaftlichen engagements knüppel zwischen die beine wirft,
wenn die halt versuchen auf eigene faust in irgendeiner form zumindest teile aspekte des problems,
zu lösen wir schon das erwähnte excel programm und zahlreiche andere initiativen die und wenn es auch nur jugend angebote sind die jetzt nicht unbedingt primär sich dagegen stellen,
was ist denn das problem wenn man sich als jugendlicher
solche gruppen anschließt dass der mangel an alternativen das ist das ist das ist die vorher der vorherrschende,
kurs unter den gleichaltrigen ist die offenbar
keinerlei andere perspektive sehen die sich generell einfach auch in diesem teilweise sicherlich auch etwas übertriebenen bild der ja und um uns kümmert sich ja sowieso keiner und dann suchen sie sozusagen irgendwann,
schutz und halt in in in dieser fehlgeleiteten argumentation des,
ja und wird ja alles weggenommen und wir sind ja hier eigentlich die opfer und dann hat man natürlich auch schnell dann die passenden täter und das natürlich dann immer die anderen so und dadurch schließlich dieser kreis und dadurch wird auch diese.
Diese befeuern diese selbst verstärkung der argumentation immer weiter,
nach oben getrieben bist du dann halt immer wieder solche,
einzelnen leute hast die bei denen das alles so verfängt und sich so sehr beschleunigt dass er halt bereit sind dinge zu tun.
Die einfach für die allermeisten leute unvorstellbar sind,
ja dann stehen sie halt wieder alle da und man ist fassungslos und man kann sich das nicht vorstellen und so eine gewalt und ach und überhaupt und wirklich und so,
ja leute kommt das gab's schon immer das nicht neu,
so dass das passiert halt einfach wenn man sich nicht nicht kümmert um das problem und vor allem wenn man sich nicht langfristig kümmern oder noch schlimmer wenn man's halt langfristig,
verhindert dann dann passiert das und deswegen passiert das und dann können wir unsere ganze tragen die puppe getragene fassungslosigkeit könnt ihr auch,
gleich wieder
in die mülltonne treten wenn er einfach als nächstes nach vorne kommt und sagt ja hier die leute die computerspiele spielen sind schuld weil anders kann ich mir die welt nicht mehr erklären,
schlimm einfach nur schlimm.
Ja das ist also dieses anne anne an dem problem vorbei.
Schießen ist können wir uns nicht erlauben und das ist in in solchen situationen.
Einfach an der tagesordnung.
Eine verhöhnung der opfer und der wirklich bedrohten leute also ich meine wie wie willst du dich denn jetzt fühlen als jude in deutschland wenn wenn so ein scheiß kommt,
wie ich mich so viele juden umbringen wieso geht schon in manifest übersetzung ja computerspiele sind das problem hallo.
Also das ist doch einfach fahrlässig also ich meine der innenminister müssen einfach wegen wegen fahrlässigkeit,
und unterlassener hilfeleistung ali hat sofort aus dem amt genommen werden,
wenn er solche sachen sagen schlimm.
Und diese diskussion also diese gamer sache ich hab das auch im gespräch mit einigen journalisten dann festgestellt die haben das gar nicht mehr so auf dem schirm.
Was eben vor ja zehn jahren winnenden,
auch los war mit killer spieler diese kinderspiel debatte die er ist hat eine eine größe angenommen eine breite angenommen,
und auch eine vehemenz ja du hast es ja gerade gesagt dass er das wahrscheinlich eine ganze reihe menschen in die,
wahrscheinlich auch netz politisiert ja dass sie irgendwie sagen ey ich spiele hier counter strike und irgendein durchgeknallte loser ballert rum und jetzt werde ich mit dem auf eine stufe gestellt.
So können wir da nochmal ein bisschen differenzieren und dann hast du schon verloren.
Ja werden.
Dahin ihr differenzieren momente abwägen.
Was was natürlich noch gesagt werden muss in dem zusammenhang ist dass dieser spinner eben auch die.
Die öffentlichkeit sucht.
Den anschluss sucht sich eben als wer im teil quasi einer eines werbe netzwerke sieht ja also,
würde mich jetzt nicht wundern wenn im weiteren verlauf eben rauskommt dass er sich von dem irren irgendwie hat anstecken.
Und dass wir davon ausgehen müssen dass hier tatsächlich eben,
das ist dass sie ihr ziel erreichen können nachahmer zu finden und das hat natürlich auch sehr viel damit zu tun,
wie viel raum man diesen leuten gibt,
um ihre gedanken irgendwie zu teilen,
und ob man denen die gefallen tut ihre namen zu nennen ihre bilder zu verbreiten.
Wie ist natürlich,
der springer verlag sofort getan hat ne mit,
ein foto und name und hasse alles nicht gesehen um
dem typen eben jetzt die genugtuung zu geben,
dann doch eine historische figur oder sonstiges zu werden.
Und das ist natürlich das war warum dann andere irgendwo sitzen,
sagen ach mensch das wär ja wenn ihr noch eine möglichkeit dass man aus mir dann doch noch was wird,
ja so statt einfach mal zu sagen der typ ist halten loser und der ist nicht nur ein loser weil er sein sein attentat oder seine mordserie da nicht hinbekommen hat seine ist auch so ein idiot,
von vorne bis hinten ist das video t.
Idiot und.
Natürlich auch 'ne 'ne verlorene seele dessen dessen dessen leben offensichtlich auch schon früher als jetzt zwei wochen vorher falsch abgewogen ist aus welchen gründen auch immer keine ahnung.
Er hat auf jeden fall der sich ja den fundamentalen herausforderungen des lebens gewidmet und hat zumindest schon mal festgestellt warte mal wie war das nochmal der feminismus ist schuld an der niedrigen geburtenrate.
Was wo kommt das her.
Ja es.
Der spinner der also er leitet ein mit den worten ist nicht im manifest sondern im video quasi hallo ich bin so und so und.
Also er er nennt sich selber in dem video anon wieder hier diese referenz zu den image sports ne und sagt auf die reihe also die geburtenrate ist gering wegen der feministinnen,
und deswegen werden wir über völkerrecht von den.
Von den arabern oder was ne und an all dem ist der jude schuld und deswegen recht er sich jetzt am juden.
Fragt man sich jetzt auf ob der nochmal seine empirische seine erkenntnisse da vielleicht noch mal feststellen könnte aber die hat er wahrscheinlich eben von.
Von irgendwelchen youtube-videos.
Ja ein loser.
So was ist denn eigentlich hier wir haben.
Hätten wir den meine arbeit schaffung maßnahme angedeihen.
Ja aber ein ausstiegs programm.
Ja hätte vielleicht hätte hätte sich hätte sich vielleicht gelohnt dem typen irgendwo noch eine perspektive zu geben.
So wir haben noch was nach zu tragen.
Ja ein thema dass ich.
Eigentlich bewusst,
hier versucht habe noch ein paar wochen zu verzögern das,
wir sicherlich auch nochmal in diesem jahr nochmal aufgreifen werden ist das der,
die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte zusammen mit,
reporter ohne grenzen netz politik org und dem european center vor konstitution human rights eine,
strafanzeige gestellt hat gegen,
die hersteller des des spionage software finns bei es gibt ja ein relativ wirges firmen geflecht primär in deutschland ansässig sind fischer,
gmbh in fischer labs und ella mann.
Die allerdings auch über ein netz aus briefkasten unternehmen verfügen um ihr produkt find's bei,
in interessante länder zu exportieren und find's bei und sind fischer.
Wir sind eine.
Ist eine schadsoftware familie für unterschiedliche betriebssysteme android windows sind bekannte ziel plattform und diese schadsoftware.
An regierungen quasi verkauft vermietet verliehen die wir haben ja hier auch im logbuch schon öfter darüber gesprochen in verschiedenen ländern,
ist dies software nachweislich zum einsatz gekommen und auch deutschland hat eine anschaffung.
In erwägung gezogen gab's diese verträge die andere meister per informationsfreiheit gesetz anfrage vor ein paar jahren schon.
An an die ans tageslicht gebracht hat.
Und in dieser strafanzeige geht es jetzt darum dass eine schadstoffe die.
Allem anschein nach finster bei ist.
Ungefähr zwanzig sechzehn in gegen oppositionelle in der türkei,
eingesetzt wurde und zwar haben sie da versucht eine software zu nach zu stellen die quasi für oppositionelle über die oppositionelle sich vernetzen könnten
und haben die quasi auf einer gefälschten webseite öffentlich zur,
zum download gestellt also diese diesen staats trojaner nicht wie es jetzt in deutschland immer nur gegen nur bei schweren verbrechen oder sonstigen.
Sondern die haben halt einfach 'ne 'ne fette ring hole angriff gemacht mit dieser spionage software und.
Jetzt ist es so dass in deutschland am achtzehnten juli zwanzig fünfzehn,
eine außenwirtschaft verordnung in kraft getreten ist die den export von duell us gütern unter genehmigungsbehörde stellt das heißt wer auch immer,
das zeug an die türkei exportiert hat hätte dafür eine ausführt genehmigung gebraucht von.
Der bundesrepublik deutschland so jetzt könnte es natürlich sein.
Wie gesagt der einsatz war glaube ich irgendwann zwanzig sechzehn.
Jetzt könnte es natürlich sein dass diese software an die türkei verkauft wurde.
Zu einem zeitpunkt der vor dem achtzehnten juli zwanzig fünfzehn lag dann müsste aber auch diese software in der version wie sie dort ist älter sein als,
der achtzehnte juli zwanzig fünfzehn eine analyse dieser software liefert jedoch eine ganze reihe an,
nicht zu widerlegen den beweisen.
Dass diese software nach dem achtzehnten juli zwanzig fünfzehn hergestellt wurde darüber würde ich,
irgendwann nochmal mehr im detail sprechen wollen.
Über diese strafanzeige haben berichtet haben alle organisationen die daran beteiligt waren berichtet unter anderem auch netz politik punkt org die eben mit,
zu der gruppe gehörten die diese strafanzeige vorbereitet und,
eingereicht haben und jetzt bitte georg hat jetzt eine abmahnung bekommen von.
Mit dem hinweis die berichterstattung sei nicht objektiv sondern hochgradig vorverurteilt dies,
folge insbesondere aus dem umstand dass die eingereichten,
strafanzeige in dem artikel eingebettet ist.
Auf diese weise würden sämtliche vorwürfe einseitig über die presse weiter verbreitet und ungefiltert,
dem leser zur kenntnis gegeben damit ist die berichterstattung selbstredend auch vorverurteilt,
entlasten die umstände werden nicht mitgeteilt die erforderliche stellungnahme der mandant schafft
wurde nicht einmal angefragt dem gemäß ist eine solche stellung name selbst reden auch nicht in den artikel eingeschlossen die gehen also jetzt gegen netzwerk org,
vor weil netzwerk org als presse medium über seine eigene strafanzeige berichtet hat.
Die anderen organisationen die genauso die den den text der strafanzeige online gestellt haben wurden nicht abgemahnt das heißt da kann man sich diese informationen auch problemlos noch holen und,
ja netzwerk hat daraufhin jetzt erstmal den artikel indem sie über diese sache berichten offline genommen.
Und jetzt jetzt eben schauen wie das aussieht in auseinandersetzung mit ihren anwälten und sagen natürlich auch sie helfen würden ihre zeit lieber dem,
kampf gegen überwachung software und zwielichtige unternehmen in deutscher hand widmen.
Und werden also jetzt sehen wie sie in dieser sache weiter verfahren.
Ich finde das sehr interessant weil.
Quasi unstrittig ist dass diese software,
aus deren also quasi zu einer zeit geschrieben wurde die nachdem in kraft treten der export restriktionen der genehmigung pflicht liegt,
es bleibt ein bisschen die frage offen ist es auch tatsächlich für den fischer.
Das aber wiederum kann tatsächlich kann das deutsche pka relativ gut
feststellen die könnte man damals zeuge fragen weil das deutsche pka hat ja testversion davon gehabt
mit anderen worten die könnten diese analysen ja auch mal durchführen und die würden werden quasi eigentlich gute gut als zeugen zu laden in diesem strahlen dieser straff sache.
Und dann wäre es natürlich spannend wenn sich jetzt bewahrheitet dass das aus den händen stammt dann wird folgendes passieren,
die werden sich dann nämlich auf ihr netz aus briefkastenfirmen beziehen,
und dann irgendwie,
wahrscheinlich aus dem hut zaubern dass sie an irgendeine eigene tor unternehmens tochter in irgendeinem anderen land verkauft haben die dann völlig eigenmächtig entgegen ihrer kontrolle,
trotzdem in die türkei geliefert hat sie aber damit nichts,
das ist das wo wo ich wovor nicht ausgehen würde was dann eine interessante debatte darüber wird wo fahren wir denn solche genehmigungsbehörde richten,
wenn die waffen hersteller diese umgehen.
Und wie stehen wir dazu dass wir offenbar selber als bundesrepublik deutschland von diesem unternehmen kunde sein möchten das ist also eine sehr spannende sache und ist eine sehr.
Sehr zu begrüßen dass hier gegen vorgegangen wird und das eben sowohl mit strafanzeigen als auch mit berichterstattung begleitet wird weil das eben eine diskussion ist die wir tatsächlich.
In deutschland mal führen müssen weil sie nämlich hier mal den finger in die wunde legt und nicht immer nur sagt hier wir müssen aber in die messenger rein ne also wir sind ja quasi.
Ein hop nur weg von der cdu reaktion auf den nazi loser aus halle,
sind wir wären wir eben bei fischer.
Natürlich klar.
Netzwerk ort wenn der so abmahnung mit unterlassungserklärung straf androhung und dem ganzen zinnober die brauchen jetzt anwälte um das problem zu lassen sich dagegen zu wehren bitten natürlich auch für ihren einsatz da um spenden die bei netzwerk ohnehin immer,
gut aufgehoben.
Ja macht sich auch gut in einem pärchen mit der mit der ebene spende so im monat so ist auf jeden fall passt gut zusammen auf dem konto.
So dann haben wir noch einen nachtrag zu der situation mit,
apple und china hat man ja kurz über dieses hin und her mit dieser.
Ist noch gleich live in hongkong,
und im app store berichtet was ja das dargestellt habe ich immer noch so sehe zunächst einmal so der übliche,
wo der absturz prozess hat festgestellt dass diese app unter umständen gegen irgendwelche regeln verstoßen kann und zwar mit regeln heißt das dann entweder regeln des appstore oder eben regeln des app stores,
die gelten weiß weitere regeln und gesetze gibt in dem jeweiligen land.
Dann gab's proteste dann hat apple rückzieher gemacht weil sie gesagt haben ja nee wir haben uns das nochmal genau angeschaut das war halt jetzt hier eine entscheidung aus unserem review team die ziehen wir jetzt mal wieder zurück.
Na ja dann war unsere sendung und danach hat sich china die hände geredet hat gesagt.
Da können wir jetzt aber auch anders und hat jetzt mal von regierung seite druck gemacht und daraufhin hat apple diese app wieder entfernt.
Das ist natürlich für diese ganze debatte nicht schön und vor allem ist das ganze auch mal in einem größeren kontext ja interessant zu beobachten weil.
Einerseits bricht es natürlich hier auf eine ganz schwierige art und weise mit den prinzipien wie apple sich selber auch darstellt und selber auch sieht und sicherlich auch oft.
Korrekt verhält.
Haben sie sich dazu geäußert.
Ja die haben sie auch dazu geäußert dass meine.
Argumentation ist natürlich auch klar und sogar auch nachvollziehbar.
Wir können ja nicht etwas tun was gegen die gesetze eines landes verstößt.
Wir können ja nichts gegen diese gesetze machen wenn wir uns entschieden haben in diesem land business zu machen jetzt ist natürlich die entscheidung in china business zu machen,
eine entscheidung die du nicht heute so und morgen so trifft und sagte so ach ja nie china und so ist das wir jetzt mal wieder sein ein viertel der weltbevölkerung.
Kannst du nicht.
Ignorieren wenn du wachsen willst so gut da kann man immer noch sagen naja jetzt ja von vornherein darauf verzichten können wie das in dem elektronik sektor aussieht in den computer business wissen wir auch dort wird produziert apple ist halt.
Langer langer langer zeit in china nicht nur irgendwie in etwas präsent sein einfach einer der stärksten player der größten produzenten von hardware und natürlich ein zunehmenden maße auch mit dem.
Kunden die können ja heute nicht raus und natürlich hängen die da wie alle anderen unternehmen auch dran und das,
das ist ganz interessant weil es in den letzten wochen gerade in den usa ganze menge,
solche sachen gibt weil china ist ja nun überall präsent und spielt überall eine rolle ja es wird natürlich dann auch gleich
nachgeliefert dass auch in dieser neuen fernsehprogramm aktions unternehmung die apple gestartet hat dieses apple tv plus und das paket was man kauft wo man halt so netflix teil
heim- produktion aus dem apple universum bekommt also apple wird jetzt quasi fernseh produzent.
Oder ist es bereits nicht und es geht jetzt irgendwie im november dann auch los und auch dort gibt's natürlich die ansage oder sind sie auch bald bin ich alleine ja so nach dem motto ja produziert mal tolle fernsehsendung aber wir können jetzt hier nichts machen wo china.
Scheiße dasteht und das hast du halt überall das hast du im sport ja.
Debatte oh die ist die ist auch echt interessant ne.
Ja erzähl mal weil er da weiß ich nicht genau was vorgefallen war was ursprünglich das ganze ausgelöst hat.
Wenn ich das jetzt grob ich kriege das mit den namen nicht auf die reihe arbeit also die.
Ist sehr groß in china sehr groß heißt irgendwie vier milliarden wert hat die chinesische und,
die haben schon vor jahrzehnten also angefangen diesen sport in nach china zu exportieren und dort eben sehr gut mitzuleben.
Und jetzt hat ein trainer eines basketball teams.
Sich relativ klar zu der zu den protesten in hongkong geäußert und dann hat die,
das risiko sehen was das für ihren markt china bedeutet hat die dann quasi versucht,
beschwichtigen sozusagen so im sinne von,
ja also wir als positionieren uns ja nicht und
gleichzeitig hat unser
der trainer dieses teams natürlich meinungsfreiheit aber wir legen wert auf die feststellung dass das sich unsere meinung ist was dann zu dem ergebnis geführt hat dass sie in den usa
natürlich vollkommen jetzt die
diese meinungsfreiheit ihres trainers eben nicht wirklich gestützt haben,
in china sie irgendwie jetzt im feuer stehen weil sie offenbar
quasi diesen trainer dass sie sich so haben äußern lassen und den nicht sanktionieren und wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe ist der aktuelle
zustand das ist also eine einen teil boykott der gerade in china gibt die also teile.
Dieser spiele nicht zeigen zumindest von der mannschaft die der trainiert hat dir trainiert,
gleiches widerfährt ja übrigens gerade hatten wir ich glaub ihr habt das in der freak show kurz besprochen die.
Der blizzard ne ist ja der hersteller von world of warcraft,
die irgendwie eine liga ausrichten und hat dann irgendwie einer der da irgendwo world of warcraft turnier gewonnen hat hat sich auch eben mit den protestieren in hongkong.
Solidarisiert und dem wurden daraufhin alle titel ab erkannt,
mein world of warcraft ist eh so ein bisschen nicht mehr in,
in in seiner größe ne also da sind eh schon ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden ast aber mit der nummer haben sie sich jetzt auch so dermaßen in essen gesetzt weil da natürlich auch diese ganzen,
gamer da sind sie wieder ne.
Thema.
Die bösen gamer natürlich auch gesagt haben nee so geht das nicht so wie wir legen natürlich wert darauf dass,
die unsere,
spitzen athleten hier meinungsfreiheit auch im politischen bereich haben und die hat auch besonders genial reagiert eben sehr verspätet gesagt so ja also es wäre ja so die regel dass die leute sich nicht politisch zu äußern haben hätten sie ja schon immer
und deswegen sollte man müsste denn sei es jetzt hier gezwungen gewesen
also zu agieren weil so wer jetzt die regeln das heißt die setzt sich da gerade auch massiv in den sesseln.
Ja und im fußball ist es ja auch so es gab ja schon wenn man das letztes jahr auf einmal diese geschichte wo der dfb so ein deal mit der mit dem chinesischen fußballverband hatte,
dass die chinesische u zwanzig nationalmannschaft.
In der regionalliga quasi außer konkurrenz mitspielt und man dann sozusagen eine ungerade anzahl von mannschaften hatte so das bei jedem spieltag eine mannschaft nicht.
Nicht spiel kein ligaspiel hat,
und dann stattdessen gegen die chinesische u zwanzig spielen soll so dass sie sozusagen so ein permanentes training gegen westliche zumindest regionalliga standards.
Projekt wurde dann auch relativ schnell auch,
reingestellt nachdem dann die zuschauer also erstmal diverse vereine auch ihre missgunst ausgesprochen und dann kam halt alle leute mit irgendwelchen tibet fahren zu diesem,
spielen und dann ist das irgendwie auch schnell abgebrochen worden es wurde jetzt auch,
anstoß zeiten verlegt in manchen liegen in europa um sozusagen kompatibel hier zu sein zu den live fernsehen zeiten in china ist also man macht sich überhaupt gar nicht klar
wie groß einig dieses interesse an westlichen sport und kultur ist ja was ja irgendwie auch ganz interessant ist weil wir haben ja nicht,
ansatz denselben dasselbe interesse an einer chinesischen kultur ich meine wer kennt schon irgendwas mit sport oder irgendwas mit.
Fernseher irgendwas sicherlich wird das langfristig,
er auch verschiedenen problemen sein
weil so sehr sich jetzt hier auch alle auf leise auf leisen sollen da durch den raum schleichen dann so ein bisschen die fresse und so haben wir auch 'ne ganze menge geld verdienen
mittelfristig wird sich natürlich auch hier ein neuer kanal auftun müssen einfach,
auch wenn es wahrscheinlich noch ein paar jahre dauert und wir alle diese ganzen maßnahmen mit überwachung mit firewall mit sperren mit.
Manipulierten suchergebnissen und so weiter und so weiter irgendwann denke ich mal wird auch diese wahlen wand,
zusammenbrechen müssen aber noch ist es halt nicht so weit und jetzt,
spielt sich das ganze ebenso ab so zurück zu apple und hongkong,
das problem wird man jetzt so nicht ohne weiteres lösen können hier ist einfach das kräfte verhältnis einfach falsch jetzt kann man natürlich apple vorwerfen.
Dass sie ja ihre werte verraten und ich glaube apple wird würde den sogar fast zustimmen nur.
Was was sollen sie jetzt machen.
Also die argumentation.
Wir müssen uns ja an die gesetze dieser länder halten.
Die finde ich ja erst mal gar nicht so wenig einleuchtend wenn wir über,
uploadfilter diskutieren dann sagen wir auch nicht youtube ist schlecht weil sie.
So etwas umsetzen ich würde aber dann natürlich schon von apple erwarten wenn sie sagen ist das ist ein gesetz dann würde ich mal ganz gerne sehen dass das auch irgendwie erklärt wird wo denn dieses gesetz steht,
ja und da könnte man natürlich schon sagen okay gegen da geben sie uns bitte ein,
rechts fegen beschluss ja geben sie uns bitte eine anordnung oder sonstiges die wir prüfen,
lassen können und gegen die wir,
uns gegebenenfalls mit unseren anwälten zur wehr setzen können um zu schauen ob das so,
bestand hat jetzt weiß ich muss ich tatsächlich sagen nicht genau inwiefern ein solcher prozess in china möglich ist und inwiefern er aussicht,
darauf hätte in irgendeiner form in die nähe von erfolg zu kommen aber es wäre natürlich schon wenigstens dass das signal hier mal zu sagen.
Okay hier sind wir auf der seite unserer nutzerinnen,
und wenn wir sagen wir müssen uns an die gesetze halten wollen wir eben auch prüfen ob das die gesetze sind.
Ja also bitte nochmal klar zu machen.
Das rechtssystem nicht.
Kuck hat sich ja selber dazu geäußert und es ist nicht so dass sie sich jetzt einfach auf diese naja und wurde das ja untersagt und deswegen haben wir das zu tun darauf zurückziehen sollen sie übernimmt teilweise eben auch diese argumentationen sagen ja die gefragte app,
berichten und cardio gravieren von polizei check punkten protest ansammlung und andere information ermöglicht was nicht falsch ist.
Für sich selbst genommen ist das nobel schreibt gucken eine e-mail dass sie für straftaten genutzt werde habe apple von der hongkong halber sicherheit und technik abteilung erfahren.
Okay auch einige nutzer selbst sollen davon berichten und die entscheidung ich hoffe aus dem app store zu entfernen sei die beste wahl zum schutz der kunden.
Wie genau argumentierte er ist der schutz zum schutz der kunde.
Hier keine weitere ausführung dieser argumentation.
Wird er vielleicht darauf anspielen dass china rechtliche hätte zu sagen sag uns wird die app installiert hat und die dann sagen können niemand das könnte.
Ich kann ich habe zu wenig einblicke in.
Ich weiß auch nicht ob irgendjemand diese einblicke hat was ihr china wissen kann,
oder gesagt bekommt in der hinsicht.
Kurzer kunden scheint mir hier glaube ich eigentlich eher ein genereller und nicht individueller begriff zu sein im sinne von so lass uns das ding mal hier raus.
Es ist besser für euch.
Es ist besser für euch ich meine.
Wir hatten ja schon darauf hingewiesen diese map ist im wesentlichen web anwendung das heißt diese app ist einfach nur so ein rapper du kannst halt das ding irgendwie auf einem packen und dann läuft das im prinzip genauso ob das dann jeder weiß ist nochmal eine andere frage.
Ich denke was auf jeden fall sehr klar ist ist du hast.
Der einfluss von china ist da.
Der einfluss von china ist da der wird nicht weggehen der einfluss von deutschland ist ja auch da.
Es ist.
Das wird halt so weitergehen dass wir also das wird so diese probleme probleme werden sich werden einfach.
Sich jetzt häufen und das ist eben das was dir passiert wenn du in eine solche.
In einem solchen in solchen staaten agierst nirgendwo anders ist das so ein großes thema wie in schiene ist auch interessant weil mein.
Niemand stellt bei apple jetzt in frage zum beispiel dass sie in der türkei ihre dienste anbieten wie von irgendwie einem vollkommen durchgeführten autokraten regiert werden.
Da stellen wir uns die frage irgendwie.
Ja also die debatten gibt's da auch schon aber es hat noch nicht die dimension ne.
Frage ob ist es den türken und türken geholfen wenn man ihn jetzt auch noch die iphones wegnimmt.
Ja eben genau.
Andererseits ist ihnen damit geholfen wenn wenn sie die weiter behalten können aber damit nichts anfangen können also es ist eine ein ein nicht auflösbar
konflikt der leider uns eben weiter beschäftigen wird und wo ich zumindest den,
den aspekt wichtig findet zu sagen gut das muss dann eben politisch gelöst werden dummerweise sind diese möglichkeiten in china eben andere als in als in demokratien.
Und vielleicht nochmal einen positiven blick muss mir immer von meinem optimismus entschuldigen aber.
Ein big picture aspekt ist ja auch was wir glaube ich hier erleben ist die wachstumsschmerzen einer.
Global einer global zusammenwachsen.
Ja also es läuft ja zwangsläufig darauf hinaus nichts anderes mit nichts anderem können wir rechnen.
Trotz aller kulturellen,
fachlichen und geschichtlichen historischen.
Trennung der einzelnen kontinente länder kulturen religionsgemeinschaften etcetera und sehen wir uns auch um die alle manchmal hassen oder einfach nicht so geil finden so.
Oder teilweise vielleicht auch mehr lieben als angemessen ist.
Die dinge schreiten sehr nah zusammen das internet hat diese ganze frage mit was ist recht eigentlich noch wert in dem moment wo es global angewendet ist und wer hat denn dann sozusagen jetzt überhaupt das primat und sicherlich versucht china
sich hier irgendwie eine gute ausgangsposition zu,
erreichen so wie sie europa und usa im prinzip auch schon immer gehabt hat ist ja nicht so dass wir nicht genauso versucht haben unsere denkweisen anderen leuten auf zu drängen und auch unsere moralische und juristische sicht der dinge,
durchzusetzen bereit et cetera.
Und das sind anpassung prozesse durch die wir jetzt durch müssen das ist natürlich jetzt in diesem fall von hongkong,
mal wieder extrem traurig und dramatisch auch und sowas werden wir auch noch oft sehen zwangsläufig aber ich glaube auch nicht dass china jetzt ein land ist was.
Überhaupt keinerlei schritte zu gehen hat und das werden wir auch sehen auch wenn sie es jetzt gerade in diesem moment nicht unbedingt zum.
Kommen wir zur letzten meldung der woche es gab ein hack back.
Und zwar,
das ist eine ganz interessante geschichte ein web entwickler aus meitingen hat sich eine eingefangen,
diese hieß music.
Und die befällt network storys von einem bestimmten herstellern das ding.
Also eure festplatten mit internet kabelanschluss.
Eure eure netzes netz lauf werke.
Und das hatte im web entwickler sehr geärgert er hat sich dann den trojaner einmal angeschaut und festgestellt wohin der film seinen command in control,
kommuniziert denn also ein trojaner funktioniert folgendermaßen also wenn ihr halbwegs klug gebaut ist.
Würfelt er entweder selber ein schlüssel oder lässt sich von dem kommenden confort server eingeben stellt aber auf jeden fall sicher
dass der auf dem coman in kontrolle gespeichert ist weil dieser commander control server soll ja nach zahlung,
musste ja diesen schlüssel rausgeben um zu entschlüsseln
damit er damit er der kunde dein entschlüsseln kann und die er hat also.
Quasi diesen commander control server so nennt man diesen den teil eines trojaner der eben aus der ferne steuert diese community control over gefunden.
Und hat festgestellt dass es sich dabei um eine.
Wiederum von anderen leuten eine eine website.
Sorry dass es sich um eine website handelte die anderen leuten gehört hatte die die angreifer aufgemacht hatten um dort ihre.
Ihre commander control server infrastruktur drauf laufen zu lassen mit anderen worten der horst mit dem mit dem dieser
diese rente wer kommuniziert hat der gehörte nicht den angreifern sondern es war ein von den angreifern gehackt der server von jemand anderem,
und weil die,
auf diesem gehacktem server hat der web entwickler hier der geschädigte in diesem fall eine offene website gefunden mit dem die die sie quasi benutzt hatten um diesen server zu infizieren,
und hat die dann genutzt und wiederum ein eigenes per gps crypt darauf zu laden das aus der sql datenbank,
die ps holt also die listen aus den quasi kunden nummern und den,
verschlüsselung schlüsseln die das ding gegen bezahlung halt rausrücken hatte irgendwie zweitausendachthundert stück.
Drin gefunden und diese liste jetzt quasi auf pace bin veröffentlicht das heißt potenziell zweitausendfünfhundert,
siebenundfünfzig leute die mit der maik musik infiziert sind.
Wir haben jetzt eine kostenlose wiederherstellung s möglichkeit weil der gute,
entwickler aus meitingen in bayern der sache mal auf den grund gegangen ist der dann auch eine spenden möglichkeit wie ihr bitcoin angeboten aber hier da gibt's den schlüssel jetzt eben.
Er kostenlos gegen spende und,
finde ich ja mal eine ganz schöne story es ist natürlich so dass der vor dem,
gesetz immer noch sich des hacks dieses service von den betroffenen personen theoretisch schuldig gemacht hat er hat immer noch etwas verbotenes getan.
Ich würde jetzt mal nicht davon ausgehen dass ihn dafür jemand anzeigt.
Aber theoretisch wäre das also auch diese handlung eben gesetzlich nicht erlaubt es stellt sich,
auch die frage.
War das jetzt okay ich würde sagen ja.
Warum sollte es nicht okay sein.
Weil er hat ja er hat ja jetzt gehackt ne das darf man ja nicht hacking ist laut in wie wir alle wissen und.
Internet ja.
Jetzt stehen wir vor dem vor dem punkt zu sagen wir wir stellen uns gegen hack back.
Aber unsere argumentation uns gegen hack back zu stellen ist ja ist ja eben die dass wir sagen dafür werden schwachstellen gesammelt dafür.
Dadurch entsteht ein schades potenzial für die allgemeinheit.
Es gibt natürlich ethische rahmenbedingungen für das hacking die ja hier in einer solchen.
Klaren verteidigungs- situation und einer notwehr handlung mein der einzige schaden sag mal so errichtet eigentlich einen großen schaden an.
Weil von den zweitausendachthundert befallenen hätte vielleicht ein drittel gezahlt die hätten jeder wahrscheinlich wenn diese standardmäßig mit tausend dollar,
zur kasse gebeten,
potentiell vielleicht sogar millionen schaden angerichtet mit seinem hack.
Bei den angreifern.
Aber immerhin immerhin ist es mal also wenn ihr euch mal jemand fragt gibt gibt's ein hack back es gibt ja wenige überlieferten fälle von hacks die die uns der.
Die uns der verfassungsschutz irgendwie nahelegt und erzählen möchte oder die uns der bundes nachrichtendienste naheliegend erzählen möchte sind glaube ich nicht dieser
dieser form mit dieser gestalt aber das wäre jetzt mal ein beispiel für jemanden der sein schicksal selbst in die hand genommen hat und so wie das hier,
klingt war das wahrscheinlich eine sache in der sache wo er nicht so lange für gebraucht hat.
Auf jeden fall coole aktion.
Herr hack ja.
Euer protestes message ja ging es nur der laut.
Tja da.
Am ende der sendung.
Am ende der sendung mit einer frohen kunde wenn ihr auch,
vielleicht zu den zu den geschädigten von musik gehört ist es doch,
bestimmt lustig wenn ihr das in den kommentaren mal erzählen würdet wie sich die situation aus eure aus eurer sicht darstellt.
Und ansonsten.
Bleibt uns nicht mehr viel zu sagen außer tschüss zu sagen.
Ich würd noch danke sagen an christopher christian thomas und hans helmut die mich besonders gefreut.
Wir sagen tschüss bis bald.
Bis bald ciao ciao.
Aux